[Música]
nuevo bloque de economía en directo
américa ya está conmigo jorge hurtado
jorge bienvenido nuevamente vamos a
comenzar hablando de asia donde se
discute la recuperación económica post
band y así es los líderes de la
asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático están reunidos desde ayer de
forma virtual por la pandemia con la
participación de eeuu china y japón el
sultán de brunei y anfitrión de la
cumbre hassanal bolkiak aseguró durante
la reunión bilateral entre las semis
japón caib lo que aumentará la
colaboración en materia de salud
seguridad y comercio con el gobierno
japonés también en la reunión raúl se
discuten las relaciones con australia y
nueva zelanda que serían complementarias
con la asociación económica integral
regional el gran ausente de la cumbre
fue mianmar el bloque dijo que la junta
militar ha realizado insuficientes
progresos en aplicar los pactos
alcanzados australia anunció la donación
de 10 millones de vacunas contra jove 19
hace como 92.6 millones de dólares en
ayuda financiera al sudeste asiático
australia y la asean acordaron
establecer una asociación estratégica
integral entre
por su parte el presidente de eeuu joe
biden anunció el fortalecimiento de las
relaciones de su país con la asian se
espera que la organización mundial de la
salud brinde un informe sobre la
pandemia que ha hecho retroceder las
economías de los países que representan
el raúl más de la mitad de la población
mundial y el 60 por ciento del producto
interno bruto mundial jorge y con todo
lo que estaba pasando en ciudadana ya se
acordó suspenderle ayuda económica de
ese país africano así es el banco
mundial anunció hoy la suspensión de la
ayuda a sudán tras el golpe de estado
militar el anuncio se produce luego de
que el jefe del ejército sudanés
disolviera al grupo de autoridades que
ejecutaban la transición del país el
primer ministro abdalá and dog y casi
todos los dirigentes civiles fueron
detenidos sudan atraviesa una profunda
crisis económica con alta inflación y
escasez de combustibles comida y hasta
medicamentos
eeuu también suspendió 700 millones de
dólares en ayuda mientras que la unión
europea amenazó con hacer lo mismo en
los últimos tres años el gobierno había
intentado reformar la economía con
sugerencia de los organismos financieros
internacionales
y van desde eliminar subsidios al
combustible y aplacar el mercado negro
pero las cifras inflacionarias llegaron
a un punto máximo en julio pasado de más
de 400 22% luego cayó en agosto al 388
por ciento y registro
365 por ciento de septiembre varias
naciones del mundo han prometido ayuda
para asistir humanitariamente a ese país
cuya economía depende de las
exportaciones de petróleo ahora en
alemania se presentaron los últimos
datos de su economía así es y uno de los
sectores más afectados sin duda es el
sector automotriz el ministro de
economía peter altmaier dijo que la
escasez de semiconductores y otros
componentes de vehículos está retrasando
la producción en su país al presentar
las perspectivas económicos de
crecimiento el funcionario agregó que el
gobierno estaba dispuesto inclusive a
apoyar la construcción de fábricas
locales de chips y que esperaba que las
subvenciones estatales movilizarán un
poco más las inversiones de parte de la
empresa privada el gobierno alemán
recortó su previsión de crecimiento para
este año al 2,6 por ciento pero elevó su
estimación para el próximo al 4,1 por
ciento esa economía se ha visto afectada
y los costos de la energía que van en
aumento en toda europa jorge le pregunto
solamente los indicadores de wasit para
después ir con la cifra el día bueno
wall street abrió mixto tras la cautela
de los inversores previo a la reunión de
los bancos centrales en asia las
acciones indias cerraron a la baja por
la disminución de la preocupación de la
oferta que pesó sobre los valores
metálicos así mejores ahora sí cifra el
día hacia la cifra del día de la
pandemia de el coronavirus va a destruir
en 2021 al equivalente a 125 millones de
puestos de trabajo en todo el mundo
según la organización internacional del
trabajo aunque la situación es mejor que
la de 2020 donde se perdieron 255
millones de empleos la hoy te advierte
de un estancamiento de la recuperación
mundial orde gracias por toda la
información que tenga un feliz resto de
vida hoy que está de cumpleaños y que
lanzamos a parís
[Música]